[Music]
everything you can see in the universe
that accounts for just 9% we don't
understand
95% of the energy budget of our unit we
still don't know what dark matter is
strong gravitational force in our
universe if you didn't have that matter
our own Milky Way galaxy would simply
fly apart and we have to explain it
[Music]
4.9 percent of our universe is made up
of ordinary stuff the stuff that you and
I and the earth and the moon and the Sun
everything we can see in the universe
that accounts for just four point nine
percent so you might be feeling very
small and insignificant in the universe
just one person on planet Earth which is
just one star and a galaxy many many
galaxies that make you feel
insignificant but take it away from this
point now actually you are truly special
because you are made up of the stuff in
our universe that's really really small
and unique so we're all very special you
can take that away um but if you ask a
physicist what they understand electrons
protons quarks all of these lovely words
that you know that's just for point nine
percent of the universe and the rest of
our universe is dark now we've got
twenty six point eight percent of our
universe is made up of something we call
dark matter it's the strong
gravitational force in our universe that
glues our own Milky Way galaxy together
if you didn't have dark matter
our own Milky Way galaxy would simply
fly apart I want to focus on this stuff
that we've called dark energy 68.3% of
our universe made up of something called
dark energy this is just the name that
we've given to some mysterious source of
energy that's making our universe expand
faster and faster each and every day
all right so I mean I'm not sure whether
you're all familiar of course what dark
energy and dark matter are really about
to mean dark energy is well related to
observations of the fact that the
universe is expanding even accelerated
and we need in some substance that
spread over the universe that explains
this and it actually was already part of
Einstein's theory along about a century
ago that he could add this possibility
of adding a constant that made the
universe expand dark matter is a totally
different phenomenon it has to do what
happens in galaxies and the fact there
is more gravity there that keeps
galaxies together but also the formation
of galaxies in the universe needs Dark
Matter but that's in hypotheses and it's
true that most theoretical physicists
and and even cosmologists and and esos
Isis think there is a despotic allowed
there that explains this additional
gravity because then you can do it with
the existing theory why would you change
the theory at work so well as Einstein's
theory if well you can add this
additional component and explain these
phenomena for me the reason to doubt
this is that there's a theoretical
reason why maybe Einstein's theory
doesn't work the way it does and this
has to do with our insights that we have
been gaining about gravity over the last
century after Einstein we learned about
quantum mechanics we've learned more
about how the cosmos works I mean at the
time of Einstein people didn't
understand even the size of the cosmos
was in fact there were galaxies so we
were dealing with an old theory and
there are reasons to believe that it
needed has to be changed that comes from
thinking about black holes and even
insights that come from string theory
which is a field I've been working on
tells you that simply representing dark
energy with this constant of Einstein's
theory and thinking about dark matter as
a particle is well may not be the right
way actually our reasons to believe that
we should modify gravity when we are
dealing with the very large distances I
mean like Einsteins the gravity works
very well when gravity is very strong
but in galaxies when we are going
further out the gravity becomes very
weak and this is where the
theory may be different and what I'd
like to explain in my way of thinking
about it is the connection between these
two objects that do phenomena the dark
energy and the dark matter
so dark energy is something that I
believe is really there in the sense
that there is a energy in our universe
that is required to explain its behavior
but the dark matter is not really a
particle it should be a an effect of the
dark the interactions between ordinary
matter and the dark energy so I have a
sort of a mixed point of view on dark
energy in dark matter that I think dark
energy is really there but the dark
matter should not be a particle but at
some way that gravity indeed works
differently in our galaxy or in our
universe when we look at the
interactions between matter and and the
dark energy this is a strange idea but
you know something is causing our
universe again expand faster and faster
it's like energies coming out of nothing
so um I can power the list of all of the
different things that it could be and
top on the list so explain this very
strange observation requires us to think
about the physics of nothingness there's
a strange thing to think about now there
are big regions of our universe where
there's absolutely nothing nothing at
all
there's no particles like we're made up
of this know dark matter expansive
nothingness nothing
apart from virtual particles that can
simply pop in and out of existence and
in doing so they give the universe
energy and this is not complete
science-fiction this has actually been
measured in laboratory you can create a
vacuum inside a laboratory and you can
measure these virtual particles that can
pop in and out of existence it's
something that comes directly from
quantum theory and is well known about
and what happens in our universe if
you've got an expanding universe we have
more and more nothingness because the
universe is getting bigger and bigger if
there's more nothingness there's more
chance these virtual particles to pop
into existence giving us energy which
causes the universe to expand even
faster it's wonderful perpetual motion
machine and it's a glorious theory and
could that be the answer to the
challenge I was set unfortunately not
because if you take the measurements
that they've made in laboratory of what
happens in that in in the lab or if you
take the theories of particle physics
our universe shouldn't exist as it does
today if the physics of nothingness as
we understand it was right our universe
should have accelerated out to a
gigantic scale long before the first
stars and galaxies ever formed so we can
tick that one off the list maybe um so
I'm going to list here of all the
different ideas of what's causing the
expansion of our universe to get faster
and faster each and every day top of the
list is this idea of nothingness the
energy of a vacuum it could just be the
particle physics got their sums wrong it
happens all the time all the time they
can't trust particle physicists no you
can maybe but sometimes they do get
things wrong that's top of the list
that's what most scientists think at the
moment to explain this mysterious
outside our universe I'm a journalist
maybe there's a new weird force field in
the universe that we know about
fundamental forces gravity keeps you
stuck on the ground electromagnetism
keeps me particles stuck together the
strong and weak nuclear force and those
are forces that act on really really
small scales those are our four forces
maybe there's a fifth that we don't know
about
one idea that's out there number three
maybe Einstein's theory of gravity is
wrong so everything that I've talked
about so far is all within a framework
that Einstein got it rights number four
the topic of our discussion today the
multiverse and that may be the answer to
this whole puzzle of why and maybe that
can explain all of these weird
observations it could be that the
particle physicists have got it right
this energy is just coming from the
vacuum but we just happen to be in a
really weird universe where the vacuum
behaves differently than we'd expect
question is I mean we we don't
understand 95% of the energy budget of
our universe if I add dark matter and
dark energy together that's an enormous
amount we don't understand we only the
laws of physics fifty right is only for
this very small bit that we do see which
is less than four percent actually we
see only one percent so the question is
what are the laws of physics that
describes the rest and I my way of doing
gravity actually combines dark energy
with dark matter in one way where you
can even explain both of them okay and
they don't Eric would you say your
theory is wrong if people do discover
the part that's good if it's possible
exist
what if they can find it does this then
provide the missing part of the current
theory which well if it provides then
dark matter
the dark matter not the dark energy one
thing at a time but it does it does and
I and I I said it briefly but let me let
me push it out a little bit the dark
matter really does look like matter does
not look like a modification of gravity
you can relate the amount of dark matter
that was in the early universe
and governs the structure of microwave
background the details of galaxy
formation and so forth
- the amount of dark matter that we
currently measure around galaxies and
things and it may agree you can you can
measure it you can consider the mass
distribution around galaxies and whether
it's consistent with a particle origin
it is etc and there are many details so
it really and and we have my favorite
the so-called axiom but there also other
many other candidates of conventional
kinds of particles if you work more or
less conventional if you work out how
they would have how many of them would
have been produced in the early universe
it's rough it's the dark it could either
you easily do the dark matter if you
calculate their properties they have the
properties in the dark matter they
interact very very weakly X with
ordinary matter not zero but weakly and
that's why we can search for them so I
completely agree dark matter is just
matter there isn't anything mysterious
about it the only problem with dark
matter is that there are a few thousand
candidates for it means what I said that
I think yeah absolutely that it's
something that has independent
motivations it's not just introduced to
address this prop this problem of dark
matter was introduced for other reasons
that are very compelling in their own
logic and and just and has all the right
properties to agree with what the
astronomers observe so the two avenues
tried I mean the the dark matter came
about by observing the strange behavior
of rotational curves in galaxies and and
and the two avenues it's not models it's
a bunch of models in each but the two
Alvin is tried in the community for four
decades now are either modify Einstein's
gravity so that you can curve space in
such a way that you get the right
throughout the rotational curves
or assume that there is a very hope a
very heavy object there that is forcing
these curves though to be a certain way
the modified gravity approaches are they
worth pursuing
absolutely it's always interesting to
try and find challenges and and
alternatives for theory but but so far
for for a long time now they've really
failed to match up with observation and
and that's credit when Stein's genius
that that his theory was is standing up
so strongly so that leaves us with Dark
Matter being exactly that matter that
that talks so weakly with other
particles and that's the only reason we
can't see it here is another thing
another thing that's worth mentioning
this connection is that there is known
kinds of dark matter neutrinos are
particles that are very very difficult
to observe the cosmological neutrino
background has never been observed
directly and they do contribute
significantly to the mass of the
universe neutrinos have been a little
heavier but they could very they would
have been this a comparable in mass to
the ordinary in fact I think they are
pretty comfortable to ordinary matter
and to the dark matter the you know the
astronomical dark matter for a long time
people thought that neutrinos in fact
before the new mass was known people
thought that in fact neutrinos might be
providing the astronomical dark have an
advantage that it was a known particle
but in any case it shows that very
conventional particles can have this
kind of behavior okay so it is dark
matter matter in that direction what
remains with dark matter is to be seen
so then we'll know which off of all
possible models we came up with for this
heavy particle that we call dark matter
he is out there now having said that
removing one one mystery out of the
picture we are still left with dark
energy and the origin of the universe
and singularities in black holes and so
on and and let's bear in mind just one
thing I'm Newton's theory of gravity
works amazingly well
even now if we need to send the rocket
to space we don't need Einstein's theory
yeah you just good enough so what we how
do we actually see this invisible dark
matter so I said I've mapped out this
dark matter you're probably thinking
well if it's invisible how the hell is
she mapped it well what we do is we look
at very distant galaxies their light
travels through the universe for about
seven billion years and as that light
travels through the universe it doesn't
travel in a straight line its path gets
twisted and pulled by the gravitational
pull of all of these invisible dark
structures around it and so what we do
is we spend a lot of time on remote
mountaintops far away from all of the
light pollution in cities and we take
very very deep images of the universe
collecting all this light from these
distant galaxies and then we interrogate
that light to tell us about its journey
it's seven billion year journey from
that galaxy to our telescope what we can
do is we can work out how its lights
been bent and distorted by all of this
invisible stuff that's out there now I
said that you said you know does Dark
Matter exists I know that something's
there I know that there's something
that's curving space and time that's
distorting these images of the very
distant universe that I map out but I
don't know what it is but I know it's
there and what we did when we when we
tested Eric's model was we said okay
what would it predict for the
gravitational pull around galaxies and
when we started working on it I was like
this smell are gonna wear this is gonna
be great we're gonna disprove this
theory in a week unfortunately not
Margo who is leading this analysis she's
a fantastic PhD student in Leiden at the
time came up with these results and she
compared our best model of what dark
matter should be with with Eric's theory
and found that it fitted our data
equally well so both theories fitted our
observations equally well and but what
was important this is what Sabine was
saying was that this new theory requires
we say no free parameter so a parameter
is it is something in your theory that
you can use to
tweet-tweet can turn the knobs to boost
the theory or lower it and there's no
free parameters in this theory and that
was very motivating and supportive of
this theory but I think you know Erik
does and team and collaborators and
indeed you've written a paper extending
this analysis this theory as well and I
think that's where we need to be going
because yeah I would love the particle
physics experiments to actually catch a
Dark Matter particle or I'd love someone
in CERN to create a Dark Matter particle
because then that piece of the puzzle
would be done and you know maybe that's
just around the corner stones going up
going through an upgrade it's going to
be colliding particles together much
faster with much higher energies than
it's ever done before maybe they'll be
enough to create a Dark Matter particle
the simplest theory that we think is out
there and we've got that bit solved but
until that happens I think we've got to
investigate new theories to watch all
the full talks and debates from these
highlights find the links below in the
description and subscribe today to the
Institute's of art and ideas
you